you have a podcast what do you what do
you have going i stream video games
so that's what i do oh yeah i've been
telling i told stevie to get you
and him on and he's like yeah i'll send
you my gamertag no wait wait what are
you playing
warzone yes you play warzone your
brother didn't tell you
no that bastard you play warzone yes
you're good every night
um all right what's your kd one point
something
let's see i don't even have that i have
a point something all right so but you
play
wait wait so do you play the island or
do you play the
you know that what's it called rebirth
island or dance or
dance so you don't do rebirth island i
haven't touched it yet
why um it's we okay how about this give
her the tour
how about this we play rebirth tonight
i'm down okay yeah we do do you have an
app where i can
where i can um you can see my face too
when we're streaming because eric
griffin does that sometimes are you on
discord
i think i can get discord yeah if you
have discord on your computer with
a camera i don't have that's the setup
right there uh so you have to do that
after the phone
yeah i gotta do the app through the
phone she's looking at you
she's like we don't have to we don't
have to stream me right
stream it but you could get my audio
right
so we'll go to verdes so now um i just
what is it pitiful
is everything okay what does your setup
look like
oh cool so good it looks like it looks
like a space station i have like three
monitors oh my god
i don't listen i don't stream and i play
yeah you don't need that no you don't
need
me crap yeah so you play um so br so you
battle roy what do you like about it
uh the fast pace i like i like really
fast-paced games and i'm usually a
sniper
so i watch over everyone yeah why okay
i'm gonna tell you about sniping oh no
i got my i got a collateral yesterday
and lost my mind
oh really what does collateral mean uh
one bullet two kills
oh wow i love when that happened yeah
because i thought you've done that
no my brother at the same time oh okay
there you go you've been the collateral
it's almost the same
yeah that one time my brother went how
did we die at the same time and i told
him i go
a sniper shot through my head and then
through your head
oh that's the worst way to die also my
brother got killed got killed last night
by um
two times by helicopter oh
yeah i mean where he was flying in right
and a helicopter is just random
yeah i mean my brother also dies in the
most you know my brother died last week
from this is that from a um
my brother died from a loadout
what's the limit so lowdon
if you gather enough money right you can
go to a buy station and buy a loadout
right it gives you
good guns the guns that you have
customized right
on and you throw down like a what a gas
can a gas canister
and then it goes a helicopter flies by
and drops this box
yeah it's not that fast it warns you
basically and it goes load out
you know exactly because the canister's
red
my brother stood he looked right
underneath the [ __ ]
thing and he died he got smashed by a
box and he died
hilarious and we laughed so hard and
then he raced out so
i got stuck by a grenade for the first
time ever yesterday and i felt like
not only did you kill me but you [ __ ]
my mom afterwards yeah
you know um sniping is cheating oh yeah
no i'm telling you it is i'm telling you
what it is
okay so um sniping is
cheating it is camping at the worst
on the worst level right because you're
not even camping
up close and personal you're camping
like a mile away
so it just it's basically you're a
coward how does the sniping work
compared to
what you do okay what i do is this right
oh god i can't even imagine what you do
bobby
whatever he's playing in here all he's
doing is
[ __ ] sniper sniper
i've seen him rage through a controller
yeah
wait what do you play on is it a is it
another station
he doesn't do pc okay you don't want you
elite as [ __ ]
i don't all right i don't do it like you
right i don't need the fancy gizmos
all right i'm like a kid like in nigeria
or whatever playing
all right i have his setup all right
shitty internet the whole thing right
and i
can still do it that's hers that's her
machine or one of them that's one of my
machines yeah wow
like if you had that set up maybe i'd
let you play more babe that's my baby
i got 30 90 in that thing how do i get
that oh good luck
what do you mean good luck you don't
think i have the finances no it's not
the finances good luck finding it
oh really [ __ ] yeah you know there's
elitist people in every [ __ ] walk of
life industry in industry
and you're one of them all right so i'm
going to say that let me go back to
sniping
i'll explain you what's next you fly in
right and you're on the roof of a
building or on a cliff
right and basically you lay on your
belly or on your knees
and you look through a sniper at my best
right you look throughout
you know i mean uh with a scope and you
see people
miles away right and you just sit there
sometimes
for 10 minutes right now just listen
all right and then you'll see some some
guy like me really in the battle
fighting people up close and personal
hand to hand hand to hand baby like a
real warrior right sam right
a knife i'm about to shoot this guy and
all of a sudden i'm dead
from somebody some [ __ ] that shot me a
mile away
yeah but that's isn't that just a
smarter strategy to be a sniper
if you want a good woman yeah you're a
woman okay if you want to um be cheap
yeah
no well no if it's like a real war i'm
not gonna hand to hand combat like i
will
find my spot and but check out what i
did yesterday
all right now what's better that or i'm
sitting there in construction zone
i'm playing i'm playing the uh rebirth
island
and when you walk into this construction
air
building let's just imagine this is the
building right there's two openings
right
but this right here is a blind spot all
right and there's like you know like
like crates i just kind of kneeled on
these crates on this corner
and i just waited even worse no it's not
yeah no no no no
no i'm trying to get in the shadows it's
a ninja
it's like metal solid what snake eyes if
you like no
no no no you're at the end as a sniper
and you should know
no no i don't even know what you're
saying so anyway people were drifting
into this construction leg
you know what i mean and i was just
shooting them shooting them
pile of bodies eight bodies i killed
eight people right
and everyone i'm playing on with my oh
dude that was great dude you know i mean
you're the best you know this and that
i know man i'm not a [ __ ] sniper like
you know i do hand-to-hand
up close and personal right so you can
also grab their [ __ ] [ __ ]
like they drop money babe right from a
mile away right
you shoot somebody you can't grab any
other [ __ ] other people get it for you
that's how you get through life
just kidding bobby i mean like the way
though okay let's defend yourself okay
sure
so what just tell them the truth
basically what bobby's saying is he
can't aim
is what it is okay so he he you spray
and pray and hope at least 40 of those
bullets hit right
i for us it's one shot one kill i mean
yesterday one shot two kills you know
you know no big deal um but you're gonna
be changing your two when i'm protecting
you
right you would love to have us on
have us on your team yeah i don't i
don't
i don't play with sniper okay you're
right i don't play with snipers
right let me ask think to myself would i
no i'll tell you why
because we play with this english guy
name um
his name is matt he has one arm and he
but he's a black belt in taekwondo and
he's from
what's welsh whales whales that whole
sentence was
magnificent thank you so he has one hand
right and he plays on council like you
right he's very talented
pc he's pc piece pc i mean and
i think his name is bush matt i don't
know what is gamma king
but he's very you've played with him
right once yeah he's a sniper guy
right what my brother doesn't like when
playing with them is that like we'll be
on a rooftop
all right and matt will get four kills
yeah
and my brother's just standing around
collecting money
being useless being useless because he
gets all the kills it's not as fun
so we don't play with them as much oh
right because you guys
you know cheat you're good aim is
your good aiming is cheap right you aim
no here's what
here i'll be honest let's be honest with
you it is skill to do it
right and here's here's my honest
opinion about it right
without snipers the games wouldn't be as
fun right because it is fun to
look out in the into the you know the
sunset to see those sparks
the glimpses that's why i have smoke
bombs i have smoke bombs so that i can
hide
right but here's what i don't like you
guys think that we
campers are cheating do you
if you get killed by a camber do you
think it's cheating okay so here's the
thing i mean when you're a sniper you're
supposed to be
hiding in the bushes somewhere and and
sniping so you're supposed to kind of
sit there a little bit right
but if you're running a mid-range gun
you should be running around
killing instead of just sitting in a
corner so that's what's actually cheaper
that we've been hating campers since
x or i mean like xbox lobbies back then
so there's there's snipers and there's
campers no no no
that's not that's true let me just i
know we're oh at the end but i just had
the article
uh no no we have to do we're doing
another segment but um we have another
thing oh just anyway
you got him flustered no you don't have
to be flustered i just need to get my
words out okay and
don't ever [ __ ] say that again okay
okay
um i got lyme disease
no here's here all right there are
campers
right that um just sit in some random
corner but
there is strategy strategic camping
right
places where no one else would even
think about going
right and that has the most flow of
traffic i think that that skill as well
to memorize a map in an environment to
do that right
is skill too right i think that people
that run around
and just start shooting people like nine
people that's just you know
you know tit for tat you know what i do
is different anyway let's move on
at the end of and and you'll see but
uh [ __ ] youtube [ __ ] you
you'll see you'll see oh i can't wait to
play tonight it's gonna be great